Playing final fantasy is an exercise of love—but even the most ardent fans can agree: the plots are full of
what in academiawe call ‘what the fuck’ type moments: Are all Cloud’s memories fake?
Is that really how inter-dimensional time travel works? People might wonder: why is Sarah
a crystal now? And my personal favorite...how is Tidus a dream? Not that he is dreaming,
Tidus literally IS a dream...You know how
many people have played a Final Fantasy game?
A lot. You know how many can accurately recount
the plot of one of these games? Very few.
Despite needlessly convoluted storytelling,
the thing that fans latch on to is the wonderfully
complex characters and their personal struggles.Even though each installment introduces a new cast,
there’s a significant amount of thematic
overlap that ties these characters together
and keeps the fans coming back for more.
At its core, Final Fantasy is a series of
games that explores the intricacies of dreams,
desires, spiritual environmentalism and well... phantasy.
I'm Jared, and this is final fantasy and psychology.
On one level, Final fantasy is an exploration
of the unconscious—it’s a jaunt into the
world of dreams. There’s a difference between
fantasy and the psychoanalytic concept of
phantasy with a (ph).
What we traditionally think of as fantasy
is something like daydreams, wishes, or desires.
Such as Vaan’s dreams of being a sky pirate in FF12 - or Cid dreaming of being an astronaut
in FF7, or Terra dreaming of her past in FF6.
Phantasy(with a ph) is the unconscious drives behind our actions that we are unaware of and
throughout the series we often see physical
manifestations of the unconscious.
Tidus is always dreaming about how much he
hates his alcoholic father, and in the same
game Seymore makes the comment that he can smell the Farplane on Auron.
The Farplane is a sort of literary allusion
to the underworld or the dream world.
In final fantasy six they literally visit
the dream world, the land of the Espers, and
fight the dream stooges: Larry, Curly, and
Moe—who [beyond the three stooges reference]
are sort of ironicstand ins for the id, ego,
and superego. In Final Fantasy seven when
Tifa and Cloud fall into the lifestream they
enter clouds unconscious memories.
In traditional psychoanalysis the analyst talks the patient through the process of naming
their unconscious phantasies and attaching language to them so that they can work out their
maladies and traumas.
Encountering and working through trauma is
one of the defining themes of the Final Fantasy
games. FF characters always have a ton of
psychological baggage.
Cyan is tasked with seeing his family on the
phantom train that carries the dead to the
other side.
Cloud goes through a whole wreck of trauma,
between the loss of his friend, the burning
of his hometown, and Hojo’s experiments
messing with his memories, Cloud is basically
broken...
And his initial reaction to trauma isn’t
the greatest.
Zidanecracks when he finds out he is a genome—a
“manufactured soulless being”...you know,
In final fantasy ten spirits become vengeful
if they can’t overcome the trauma of their
death and Rex (from Final Fantasy twelve)
is so shaken by surviving the murder of his
family that he is institutionalized.
Then there is the sorry case of Vivi, the
saddest little scarecrow in blackface, in
the history of gaming.
His loss is not just the mourning of a friend
or loved one—it is something akin to Freud’s
discussion of melancholia, of a self directed sadness beyond object loss—what Vivi has
lost can never be regained, the innocence
of youth, of the belief in immortality.
Vivi finds out that he is just a mass produced
war doll with a shelf life of about a year.
The mage is just sort of wakes up to consciousness—are thrown into the world like Frankenstein’s
monster—disconnected from their creator and radically without purpose.
This existential quagmire is a microcosm for
the human condition, as finite beings we all
grapple with the question: “what does it
mean to be a being that will one day die?”
How is he supposed to go on with this knowledge seems to be his central character arch and
the hint is there, the name Vivi, is literally
Italian for life: so the answer—find a way
to live.
One reaction to Trauma is also one of the
best parts of Soap Operas: amnesia. The way
soap operas write characters that they have
killed back onto the show is pretty hilarious:
no, your favorite soap hunk isn’t really
dead, he has amnesia, or he is really his
evil twin.
I wish that Final Fantasy were different...I
really wish that it was, going back over these
games the most frequent plot hole fix: is
of course, amnesia...
In final Fantasy six, Terra can’t remember
being an Esper and Rachel falls off of a bridge
and loses her memories, in seven Cloud has
all sorts of false memories, in Final Fantasy
eight Selphie, Quistis, Seipher, Ellone, Zell,
and Squallwere all somehow suppressing a memory
of living in an orphanage together as kids.
In Final Fantasy nine Fratley is suffering
from amnesia, Garnett forgot a giant eye in
the sky that destroyed her city, and Fang has
in final fantasy thirteen also has amnesia.
But none of this compares to Tidus, yeah we
are going there again, what the fuck? Tidus
doesn’t just have amnesia, he has forgotten
that he isn’t a real boy, he is actually...a
dream. I’m sorry, I just can’t get over
this.
When people think of the “Fantasy” element of Final Fantasy they often think of something
like LAARPING and the magic that gives it
the fantasy feel. But lest we forget that some
are decidedly sci-fi, the real phantasy that
binds these games is a struggle with trauma.
While each big boss has an interesting justification
for their actions—most also act as a
response to trauma. Looking for a way to explain the motivation of soldiers returning from
world war I, afflicted with motivation that
was inexplicable using his drives based on
Eros or sexuality—Freud coined the term:
the Death Drive or Death Instinct... sometimes
called Thanatos.
The death drive is an instinct or a drive
towards self destruction—it’s a desire
to return to inorganic chemistry—where all
desires are satisfied—it is a desire to
be free of conflict or suffering. Kind of
like curling up on a couch with some ice cream
and Sherlock forever. This manifests in a desire either for self annihilation or apotheosis
(a desire to transforminto a god), and much
like Prometheus, Phaethon, or Icarus—cutting
corners on a path to divinity doesn't usually
end well.
In Final Fantasy nine Kuja’s response to
his finitude and inevitable impending death is:
destroy all life with him, in one blaze of glory.
In Final Fantasy seven Sephioroth is an abandoned
and lonely soul that attempts to gain ultimate
power by harnessing the lifestream of the
planet by hitting it with a giant meteor.
Many of these antagonists justify their actions
from the perspective of negative utilitarianism.
Unlike traditional utilitarianism that attempts
to maximize happiness, negative utilitarianism
is about minimizing suffering.
And the surest way to insure that there is
net less suffering forever is to quickly snuff
out all life so that it can never suffer again.
In Final Fantasy thirteen the Fal’C want
to eliminate all disharmony and suffering
by bringing back the maker to reestablish
order and peace.
In Final Fantasy ten, Seymour grew up with
all of the suffering, taunting, and harassment
of being a half-breed. So his solution? Help Sin destroy all of Spira
to end all suffering on the planet.
With all of the crystals in the final fantasy
series, overlooking the new age spirituality
would be a mistake, exemplified by shops that
sell incense, wind chimes, Australian Didgeridoos,
polished rocks, and a lot of crystals.
The new age movement gained traction in the 1970’s and is an amalgam of spiritual beliefs
that stressed holistic divinity and the interconnectedness
of all life.
While not necessarily related to New Age spirituality, The Gaia Hypothesis is similar in that it
asserts that the earth is one harmonious living system—and disrupting that system has serious
implications for everyone living on the Earth.
Final Fantasy seems to take a lot of inspiration from the Gaia hypothesis. In Final Fantasy
seven all life goes back to the planet as
lifestream, in Final Fantasy twelve, nine,
and seven the planet is aptly named Gaia.
Whether it’s an evil corporation or a megalomaniac
moving crystals or statues around—the games focus on balance with the environment. And
as such, is full of environmentalist undertones.
In seven Cloud is in cahoots with an environmental terrorist group that challenges the exploitative
Shinra corporation. The Al Behd in final fantasy ten are the last users of machina(a type of
technology)... whereas most of the world is anti technology. Sin is sort of like a mix between the
Unabomber and the Sea Shepard...if they were a giant whale beast... thing. Its purpose
for existence it to punish people for using
technology. But to focus just on technology
misses out on the root of the problem.
Something more is going on than your usual
captain planet, tree hugger affair. Final
Fantasy seven tips it’s hat, with the introduction
of a minor character: Heidegger.
That’s right, The Notorious Martin, himself,
the master of being and time makes an appearance
as the head of public safety for the Shinra
corporation.
In his work "The Question of Technology? Martin
Heidegger asks: what is the essence of Technology?
Heidegger's answer: nothing technological-rather
the drive to technology is based not in machines
but in a particular type of thinking and seeing
called enframing.
Enframing renders the totality of the field
of vision, or the earth, to bestand-or standing
reserve, as matter simply waiting to be exploited
for us.
The way the Shinra Corporation merely sees
lifestream as a means to make the profitable
substance mako, or how Draklor laboratories
artificially create nethicite, how the fal’C
are enslaved to power the citiesof Cocoon
or extracting magic from Espersare all examples
of enframing.
It stems from an in-authentic need to master
and control the world—to settle the wilderness—to
pacify the precocity of life by making everything
needed ready at hand. However, —the urge
to mastery doesn’t just end at objects.
When humanity views life from the perspective
of instrumentality, human beings themselves
are seen as standing reserve—as materials,
as a means to an end: it’s a form of objectification
and subjugation.
Throughout the entirety of the series there
are odd parallels between the world and politics
of Final Fantasy and the fascist, genocidal
regimes of earth.
A couple of shared elements might be a coincidence but Final fantasy four’s murderous antagonist
is called Golbez, which bears a striking resemblance to the minister of propaganda for the Nazi
Reich: Paul Joseph Goebbels.
Jewish imagery is interspersed throughout
the games: Sephiroth is close to Sephirot,
the ten attributes of god.
Final fantasy thirteen takes place under the
backdrop of the relocation and mass execution
of the l’cie called the purge... l’cie
are a branded people chosen by Fal’c gods
and final fantasy seven takes place under
the guise that they will return to the promise
land... complete with a Joseph Mengele like character in the maniacal Hojo. (Mengele,
of course, was one of the Nazi doctors responsible
for selecting people for the gas chambers
and human experimentation in Auschwitz.)
Experimentation and objectification is a constant
theme in final fantasy. In 8, Edea is possessed
by Ultimecia to help advance her mastetr plan
to posses people in several time lines. Celeste
is created through genetic engineering in
final fantasy six. In final fantasy thirteen
Cocoon is a giant production facility to create
human thralls for the Fal’C and just like
prison sex, Kuja does what is done to him,
creating a production facility of black mage
dolls as weapons that reflect his own empty
puppet like existence as a genome.
Also- trains. Final Fantasy six has the phantom
train, final Fantasy seven has several trains,
final Fantasy eight has the timber train,
Final Fantasy nine has an air cab that is
a sort of monorail, Final Fantasy twelve has
abandoned railroad tracks everywhere and in
Final Fantasy thirteen trains transport l’cie
to their mass extermination.
The role of railroads are significant given
the history of their use for the acceleration
of the mass exodus and elimination of people
in Nazi Germany - and through facilitating
the extermination of the native people of
North America through the expansion of the
western border into indigenous lands.
Trainshave always been symbol of technological advancement—they stand as the archetype
of the industrial revolution and manifest destiny.
In Dostoyevsky's 'The Idiot', trains were even a symbol of the Antichrist.
As a sort of bad omen trains are a reminder
of the power of technology and the responsibility
that comes with wielding immense power.
Whether it be medieval times or space epics, in Final Fantasy, magic is treated pretty
similar to technology and in some instances they are used interchangeably.
It isn’t a question of technology or magic
being bad in and of itself—the responsibility
lies in hands that use the tools or cast the spells.
Final Fantasy, in the end, is about the unbreakable human spirit, about overcoming impossible
odds, of persevering when success seems like
a pipe dream or fantasy—it’s about the
power of friendship, love, and the transformative
potential of hope...
No one decides to sacrifice their
lives in Final Fantasy ten—they all choose
to accept a world of death, suffering, and
pain. All the party members in Final Fantasy
seven find a reason to fight for the planet,
in Final Fantasy nine the party fights against
Necron and asserts a will to live.
Even angst filled Vivi finds the will to make
little Vivi babies.
In Final Fantasy six they respond to Kefka’s
nihilism with “it’s the day to day concerns,
personal victories, and the celebration of
life and love...that matters.”